momento de actualizar la información
económica en france 24 y por ello le doy
la bienvenida a mi compañero luís méndez
louis iniciamos con la preocupación
existente por la crisis de la cadena de
suministros que se presenta a nivel
mundial así es una situación que ha
generado desabastecimiento en algunos
países y ha causado temor ante la
posibilidad de que las ventas navideñas
se vean afectadas por la llegada tardía
de productos a los anaqueles en eeuu el
poder ejecutivo habría intervenido para
el establecimiento de un acuerdo y que
el puerto de los ángeles en california y
otro en el mismo estado operan en 24
horas siete días a la semana con la
finalidad de aliviar los denominados
cuellos de botella que tienen varios
buques varados con mercancía esta
situación a nivel macro está
obstaculizando el proceso de
recuperación económica en la nación y
estaría presionando el aumento de la
inflación dentro del país que se ubicó
en septiembre en 5,4 por ciento a nivel
interanual pero escuchemos que dijo el
presidente de eeuu sobre el tema
quiero ser claro este es un compromiso
generalizado de ir a las 24 horas los 7
días de la semana es un gran primer paso
para acelerar el movimiento de
materiales y mercancías a través de
nuestra cadena de suministro pero ahora
necesitamos que el resto de la cadena
del sector privado también se sume en
este orden de ideas la empresa apple
anunció este miércoles que podría
disminuir la producción de su nuevo
teléfono iphone 13 a 10 millones de
unidades debido a la escasez de chips un
tema que también guarda relación con la
crisis en la cadena de suministro y los
efectos que dejó la pandemia de kobe 19
luisiana pasamos a europa porque la
unión europea ofreció al reino unido un
paquete de medidas para facilitar el
tránsito de mercancía a irlanda del
norte y lo primero que se debe explicar
es que si bien en irlanda del norte
pertenece a reino unido este territorio
forma parte del mercado único de la
unión europea debido a su frontera
abierta con irlanda en este sentido el
bloque de los 27 buscas con estas
medidas reducir los trámites por lo
menos la mitad para el traslado de
mercancías del resto del del reino unido
a irlanda del norte la situación en la
que él anda del norte forma parte del
reino unido pero se rige comercialmente
por las normas unión europea ha generado
problemas en el comercio de este
territorio con el resto del país y por
ello londres ha manifestado que el
acuerdo no funciona pero escuchemos que
dijo el principal funcionario de la
unión europea para el break si
proponemos ampliar el alcance del
sistema existente sobre bienes que no
ocurren el riesgo de entrar en el
mercado único de la unión europea a un
grupo más amplio de empresas y productos
en pro de 12 mil cementos stability no
sólo consolida la estabilidad la
previsibilidad y los ingredientes
indispensables para que fortalezca la
economía local sino que también allana
el camino para mejores oportunidades o
por cien x
louis vamos ahora américa latina' porque
chile apuesta por la explotación del
litio se desprende de un comunicado
emitido por el ministerio de minería de
ese país este miércoles en el que
expresa que la convocatoria busca
asignar contratos especiales para
explotar y producir 400.000 toneladas de
litio metálico comercializables
divididas en 8 cuotas de 80.000
toneladas cada una además la propuesta
también prevé el establecimiento porque
chile cuenta con las mayores reservas de
litio con 92 millones de toneladas según
el último informe del servicio de
geología de estados unidos luís díaz
argentina podría llevar a cabo una nueva
congelación de los precios de los
productos básicos fue un anuncio
realizado en este caso por el secretario
del gobierno que ya ha mantenido
conversaciones con las principales
empresas de ese país de acuerdo con el
diario argentino clarín la petición pesa
sobre mil 245 productos de consumo
masivo y podría extenderse por 90 días
la medida busca evitar un aumento en la
inflación que en el mes de agosto se
ubicó en 2,5 por ciento mensual y 5 14 a
nivel interanual de acuerdo con la nota
los empresarios han pedido también un
congelamiento para los proveedores de
materias primas y el banco mundial insta
a los países a hacer más para ayudar en
las deudas a las naciones con menos
ingresos podría conocerte y malpas
presidente del organismo este miércoles
dos días después de que esa institución
presentase un informe sobre el aumento
de la deuda en los países de menos
ingresos pero escuchemos qué fue lo que
dijo
estamos hablando de una reversión del
desarrollo y una parte de eso es que las
cifras de pobreza están aumentando
entonces cómo puede el banco mundial
interactuar con eso bueno podemos
identificar país por país donde están
ocurriendo las reversiones que en
general es en todo el mundo y luego
intentamos lo que podemos hacer como
identificar formas en que el mundo puede
solucionar estos problemas
[Música]
louis en nuestra cifra del día tiene que
ver con los 4.3 millones de dólares que
fue el valor del comercio exterior de
china durante los tres primeros
trimestres del presente louis vendes
muchas gracias por la información
económica y ustedes también muchas
gracias por sintonizarnos quédense con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]